we get a million three properties of
inverse functions we went ahead and we
need to find them yesterday and we look
briefly on how to do some of the very
simple computation like how do i how I
get an inverse you know that's the most
basic thing but now we want to
understand in the similar way to how we
did it with integration right it's okay
here's an integral get used to doing the
the--of integrating will be the palette
reversal not getting confused of
differentiation then we went ahead and
we did things like it for instance this
is a definite integral right and because
we know something about it we can take
advantage of a property that even
functions have I just picture in your
mind what an even function would look
like and therefore what it would look
like if you integrated from negative a
to some opposite boundary what would be
able to say - yeah very good - x naught
to a good so we slice it right down the
middle a and of course the reason why
such a property is useful to know it is
OOP scuse me why is the right-hand side
generally gonna be useful to us why not
just do this we get obviously we're
looking at situation where I can do it
this thing right so why did you this
over this suggestion fantastic when I go
ahead and I evaluate this right that's
going to be nice generally speaking
putting zero into things we're really
good at doing that and that often makes
these super super simple as opposed to
what I have on the left hand side if I
just you know evaluate that that's gonna
be yeah for one thing and that might
just give us more algebraic work and
more places for everything right so
that's what we mean by copies of
something we understand how to integrate
anything you like okay let's let's do
some fancy stuff and that's exactly what
going to do today okay increasing
decreasing functions now we have
introduced the language it's increasing
and decreasing functions before let's
draw an increasing function over here
something like that
that's an increasing function don't know
what it is I'd guess it's a cubic from
what I've drawn women and a decreasing
function maybe something like I'll just
do a simple okay so we have an intuition
in our minds for increasing decreasing
function if you were to explain this to
someone who may be say was in you ten
they've met grass before what sentence
would you give them to say oh this is
how you recognize what an increasing
function is and here's how you recognize
what a decreasing function is how simple
could you boil it down which ties it is
a hidden right hand side okay so if you
track along from left to right easy
going up where is it going down that's
cooking someone give me another one
another way you might articulate how
steep it is now that's interesting
because I I kind of see what you're
going to Anna Kiel I'm right on that
other with
interesting I'd probably say like just
thank you he's making probably not I
think you get a look sort of like a 10
what you do however take your points
right and in fact I'm gonna I'm gonna
draw it a little more that if you were
to draw like imagine a whole series of
Wyatt driving wants to move one a whole
series of straight lines that are
nestled up along the curve that's how I
would put it just touching by the same
tangent because that's what take it
means well they are all doing the same
thing that Nikki Lewis described right
they're all pointing in that direction
all they're all pointing in this
direction
yeah ok now we are at the right point in
the course where it's appropriate to
actually have a rigorous definition for
this tactic okay
so if you have another color then what I
want you do is pick two points any two
points will do the increasing one first
and then we'll do the decreasing big any
two points on your curve now on a circle
and on any okay if you pick any two
points and you join those together with
an interval right what do we call such a
shape or a circle which sort of we will
use that same when we call that a chord
right that's a chord it doesn't it's not
a line
why that goes on forever but it's an
interval it starts and it ends so I call
this my chord we look to quarter the
parabola underhanded tricks of Maca
similar kind of things so on any kind of
current state and cold is a point I want
you to think about or ever I told you
you can draw your two points you can
plot them any way you like
right so we all have our chords in
different spots however every single
chord we've all drawn shares a property
right it's the same thing you were kind
of screaming but can you explain it in a
vigorous sorry clearest in a rigorous
way not like a oh it's going up
how would you articulate it here what
would you say yeah fantastic
I'm gonna go with that right I could say
the gradient of this point right and I
just have two points so I can just use a
ring
like if I like sorry the gradient of the
court is going to be greater than zero
now interestingly I haven't I
deliberately didn't do all this work I
haven't got any stationary points on
this graph you can picture a graph like
say like an excuse would you call that
an increasing function so they are the
basic answer is or parishes have the
technical answers the technical answer
is yes Mike was actually is an
increasing function how web bar so I can
say this for increasing but so I'm okay
I'm okay with points where I level off
okay
however because you know there is this
kind of like oh yeah but really we
introduced language to try and
distinguish between these two cases so
if the grading of the chord is positive
which the word positive excludes zero
right we say actually this is this is
more specific frets and we call this
strictly increasing now the relationship
between these two is kind of even though
you might not think of it right now it's
kind of a calculus relationship right or
attackers distinction because this one
is saying yeah put your points anywhere
have a chord right but this guy is kind
of like imagining a chord and allowing
you to have chords of length zero does
that make sense
because if I allowed myself to have
chords of like zero this is a problem
for me right because there will be that
one point at the stationary point where
it's not in fact got a positive brain
it's got a gradient of zero right but if
you say ya know even at a single point
right you have a positive gradient your
chord then becomes a tangent right we
call it strictly increasing is
definitely everywhere always increasing
I guess you could then make a statement
about the derivative the gradient
function and of the gradient function
misadventure noise okay let's draw the
corresponding diagram on two
decreasing function which of course is
everything but you nervous right so
that's the idea that a tangent is the
limiting case of a cord all right so
it's kind of like this is one of those
cases where you like can we imagine
something with length 0 and the answer
is we calculus we can but without
calculus these court these two points
have to be distinct otherwise there's no
cord right so that's why these kinds of
different cases for are you in calculus
mode at the moment are you willing to
deal with the fact that sometimes you
can have things that that don't exist
they're there at a point or are you know
I really just think you have two actual
points I know what a calculator gradient
so here of course we'll go and you can
you can complete your city okay
now increasing thank you Miss Minchin's
that's nice you actually already knew
this knowledge is trying to refine your
definition how is this going to relate
to inverse functions okay don't shout
anything else yet just look at it and
see geometrically maybe it might help
you if you add to your diagrams our y
equals x line
in order to find the inverse of a
function we need these men obviously we
know how to dodge bravely you have no
definition for the expression here so
you can't do that but you can still find
something for the inverse because we
drew this decreasing function a little
simpler we could go and ask what this
thing look like if I reflected it across
y equals x how would you describe it now
the first thing to do is to say okay
look at this one conveniently it crosses
y equals x ok if it's a decreasing
function
kind of has to write anyway
therefore the easiest point you know
interact graphs are like ok if you
squeeze your waist contoso you already
square one
oh is it going to go taste one point on
this graph that is easier to think about
than all the rest of the points when
you're trying to do this reflection
thing which point is it it's the point
of intersection right this guy right
here because when you reflect it across
y equals x it stays right it doesn't
need to go anywhere right so that's kind
of nice what's happening when you're
having a look at say this side of the
graph over here look like what you'll do
is you're reflecting across right
there's a very similar shape doesn't
because of the way we've drawn it what
you want to do and you can literally
unfortunately I cannot move off maybe
fortunately my wife bought off that wall
and turn it but you can turn your page
so that your y equals x line is vertical
we are much better at seeing symmetry
when it's lined up across our field of
vision so move it sauce vertical and
then do the reflection it's not that
hard right on mine I'm gonna do my best
to turn my hair it's not gonna be
identical I think mines gonna come off a
little bit like this like this it's
slightly flat on mine anyway
okay so you also be slightly different
so you can see here in balloon if I call
the black one F X Y X my blue graph is y
equals F inverse of X now tell me what
kind of function is out invest in this
case in terms of increase of decreasing
it's still decreasing isn't it and it
kind of has to be right if it's
decreasing over here when you reflected
across because if the wide where if we
use it's going to keep on decreasing and
the same thing happens when you do it
the other way okay now this one's a
little more difficult but it's not
impossible
and the one we've drawn here I think
it's gonna look a bit like a bars right
again turn your page turn your page so
you can see that vertical and then just
think about okay I want this on the
other side all reflect across right on
mine I think it's gonna look like this
what do you think okay
Jordan the bone color which is not very
helpful I'll redraw it okay you've got
yours there as well again what kind of
statements can you make about what kind
of function universes it's still
increasing right in exactly the same way
except the arguments just in Reverse
okay so this is just a very brief visual
argument you can make a similar one-off
calculus which we're not going to do
just yet but I've shown you have a
different shape
um the inverse of an increasing function
is increasing the inverse of a
decreasing function decreasing and
that's a really important property to
understand okay so let's just state that
okay the so first important thing hope
that makes sense it's some simple
geometry I'm going to repeatedly go back
to algebraic and geometric definitions
for what inverses are to understand what
is going on and this is a really easy
argument honest